The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
SHAN-YUAN HO: OK.
So today's lecture
is going to be on
Finite-state Markov Chains.
And we're going to use
the matrix approach.
So in last lecture, we saw
that the Markov chain, we
could represent it as a directed
graph or as a matrix.
So the outline is we will look
at this transition matrix and
its powers.
And then we'll want to know
whether this p of n is going
to converge for very,
very large n.
Then we will extend this to
Ergodic Markov chains, Ergodic
unichains, and other
finite-state Markov chains.
So remember in the Markovity,
these Markov chains, the
effect of the past on the future
is totally summarized
by its state.
So we want to analyze the
probabilities of properties of
the sequence of these states.
So whatever the state you are
in, all the past is totally
summarized in that state.
And that's the only thing
that affects the future.
So an ergodic Markov chain is
a Markov chain that has a
single recurrent class
and is aperiodic.
So this chain doesn't contain
any transient states.
And it doesn't contain
any periodicity.
So an ergodic unichain is just
ergodic Markov chain, but it
has some transient
states in it.
So the state x sub n of this
Markov chain at step n depends
only on the past through
the previous step.
So for n steps, we want
to be at state j.
And then we have this path.
x sub n minus 1 is i, and
so forth, up to x0.
It's just the probability
from i to j, from
state i to state j.
So this means that we can write
the joint probability of
all these states that we're in,
so x0, x1, all the way up
to xn, as a function of these
transition probabilities.
So in this transition
probability matrix, we can
represent these transition
probabilities.
We see that here, in this
example, this is a 6-state
Markov chain.
So if I want to go from, say,
state 2 to state 1 in one
step, it would just
be p of 2,1.
If I want to go from
state 6 to itself--
this is last one, which
is p of 6,6.
So this is a probably
transition matrix.
So if we condition on the state
at time 0 and then we
define this p of ijn is equal to
the probability that we're
in state j at the n-th step,
given that we start x0 is
equal to i, let's look at what
happens when n is equal to 2.
So in a 2-step transition,
we go from i to j.
It's just the probability that
at step 2, x2 is equal to j,
x1 is equal to some k,
and x0 is equal to i.
So remember, we started
in state i.
But this has to be multiplied
by probability that x1 is
equal to k, given that
x0 is equal to i.
And we have to sum this over all
the states k, in order to
get the total probability
from--
Oh, stand back?
OK.
There.
So this is just probability
of ij in two steps.
It's just the probability of
i going to k times the
probability of k going to j,
summed over all k states.
So we notice that this term
right here, the sum over k or
ik, kj is just the ij term of
the product of the transition
matrix P with itself.
So we represent this
as P squared.
So we multiply the transition
matrix by itself.
This gives us the 2-step
transition matrix of this
Markov chain.
So if you want to go i to j, you
just look at ij element in
this matrix.
And that gives you the
probability in two steps,
going from state i to state j.
So for n, we just iterate
on this for
successively larger n.
So for n state to get from state
i to state j, we just
have this probability x sub n,
given j, given x of n minus
the previous step is equal to
k, x sub n minus 1 equals k,
given x0 is equal to i,
summing over all k.
So this means that we broke
this up for n-th step.
In the n minus one step,
we visited state k.
And then we multiplied that
one-step transition from k to
j because we want to arrive
at j starting at i.
But again, we have to sum over
all the k's in order to get
the probability from
i to j in n steps.
So p of n right here, this
representation is just the
transition matrix multiplied
by itself n times.
And this gives you the n-th step
transition probabilities
of this Markov chain.
So computationally, what you do
is you take p, p squared, p
to the fourth.
If you wanted p to the 9th,
you'd just take p eighth
multiplied by p, to to
multiply by this.
So this gives us this thing
called the Chapman-Kolmogorov
equations, which means that when
we want to go from step i
to step j, we can go to an
intermediate state and then
sum up all the states that
would go into the
intermediate state.
So in this case, if the step is
m plus n transition, we can
break it up into m and n.
So it's the probability that it
goes from i to k in exactly
m steps and k to j in n steps,
summing over all the k's that
it visits on its way
from i to j.
So this is very useful a
quantity that we can
manipulate our transition
probabilities when we get
higher orders of n.
So the convergence
of p to the n.
So a very important question we
like to ask is as n goes to
infinity whether this goes
to a limit or not.
In other words, does the initial
state matter, all
initial sates matter in
this Markov chain?
So the Markov chain is going
to go on for a long, long,
long, long, long time.
And at the n-th state where n is
very large, is it going to
depend on i?
Or is it going to depend on n,
which is the number of steps?
If it goes to this quantity,
some limit, then it won't
depend on this.
So let's assume that
this limit exists.
If this limit does exist, we can
take the sum of this limit
and then multiply it by p of
jk, summing over all j.
So we do a sum of over j.
So we're going from j to
k on both sides, and we
sum over all j.
So we take this limit
right here.
We notice that this left side
going from i to k to n plus 1
is just that this limit
at state k exists.
Because we saw assumed up here
that this exists for
all i and all j.
So therefore, if we take the n
plus 1 step, we take this n
going to infinity of i to k,
it has to go to pi of k.
So when we do this,
we could simplify
this equation up here.
And if it doesn't exist, we have
this pi sub k for all the
states in the Markov chain.
So this is just a vector.
So pi sub k is equal to pi sub j
times the probability from k
to j, summed over all j.
So if you have an m state Markov
chain, you have exactly
m of these equations.
And this one, we'll call it the
vector pi, which consists
of each element of this
equation, if the limit is
going to exist.
But we don't know whether
it does or not, at
this point in time.
So if it does exist, what's
going to happen?
So that means I'm going to
multiply this probability
matrix, P times P,P P, P,
P, P, P all the way.
And if the limit exists, then
that means for each row, they
must be all identical.
Because we said the limit
exists, then going from 1 to
j, 2 to j, 3 to j, 4 to
j, they should be
all exactly the same.
This is also the equivalent of
saying, when I look at this
large limit, as n is very,
very large if the limit
exists, that all the elements
in the column should be
exactly the same as well,
or all the rows.
So the elements are equal to
each other, or all the rows,
if I look at the row, which is
going to be this pi vector.
They should be the same.
So we define this vector.
If this limit exists, the
probability vector
is this vector pi.
Because we said it was an
m state Markov chain.
Each pi sub i is non-negative,
and they obviously have
to sum up to 1.
So this is what we call a
probability vector, called the
steady-state vector,
for this transition
matrix P, if it exists.
So what happens is this limit
is easy to study.
In the future in the course, we
will study these pi P, this
steady-state vector for
various Markov chains.
And so you see, it is quite
interesting, many things that
could come about it.
So we notice that this
solution can
contain more than one.
It may not be unique.
So if it contains more than one,
it's very possible that
it has more than one solution,
more than one probability
vector solution.
But just because a solution
exists to that, it doesn't
mean that this limit exists.
So we have prove that
limit exists, first.
So for ergodic Markov chain,
here we have another way to
express this that this matrix
converges is that the matrix
of the rows--
the elements in the column are
all the same for each i.
So we have this theorem.
And today's lecture is going to
be completely this theorem.
This theorem says that if you
have an ergodic finite-state
Markov chain-- so when we say
"ergodic," remember it means
that there's only one class,
every single state in this is
recurrent, you have no transient
states, and you have
no periodicity.
So it's an aperiodic chain.
And then for each j, if you take
the maximum path from i
to j in n steps, this is
non-increasing in n.
So in other words, this right
here, this is non-increasing.
So if I take the maximum path
from state i to j, it gives
you exactly n steps.
So that means this is
maximized over all
initial states i.
So it doesn't matter what state
you start, and I take
the maximum path.
And if I increase n, and I take
maximum of that again,
the maximum path, this
is not increasing.
And the minimum is
non-decreasing in n.
So as we take n, the path from
i to j, this n getting larger
and larger, we have that the
maximum of this path, which is
the most probable path,
is non-increasing.
And then the minimum of this
path, the least likely path,
is going to be non-decreasing.
So we're wondering whether
this limit is going to
converge or not.
In this theorem it said that
for an ergodic finite-state
Markov chain, this limit
actually does converge.
So in other words, the lim sup
is equal to lim if of this and
will equal pi sub j, which is
the steady-state distribution.
And not only that, this
convergence is going to be
exponential in n.
So this is the theorem that
we will prove today.
So the key to this theorem is
this pair statements, that the
most probable path from i
to j, given n steps--
so this is the most
probable path--
is non-increasing at n,
and the minimum is
non-decreasing in n.
So the proof is almost trivial,
but let's see what
happens in this.
So we have a probably
transition matrix.
So this is the statement
right here.
And the transition is just one
here and one here, with
probability 1, 1.
In this case, we want to say,
what is the maximum path that
we're in state 2,
given n steps?
So we know that this probability
alternates between
1 and 2, it's non-increasing,
it's not decreasing, it's
always the same.
So those two bounds are
met with equality.
So in this here.
So the second example is this.
We have a two-state
chain again.
But this time, from 1 to 2, we
have the transition of 3/4.
So that means that we have
a chain here of 1/4.
See, the minute we put a
self-loop in here, it
completely destroys
the periodicity.
Any Markov chain, you put a
self-loop in it, and the
periodicity is destroyed.
So here we have 3/4.
So this has to come
back with 1/4.
All right.
So in this one, let's look at
the n step going from 1 to 2.
So basically, we want
to end up in state 2
in exactly n steps.
So when n is equal to 1,
what is the maximum?
The maximum is if you start it
in this state and then you
went to state 2.
The other alternative is you
start at state 2, and you stay
in state 2.
Because we want to end at state
2 in exactly one step.
So the maximum is going to
be 3/4, and the minimum
is going to be 1/4.
You get n is equal to 2.
Now we want to end up in
state 2 in two steps.
So what is going to
be the maximum?
The maximum is going
to be if you visit
state 1 and then back.
So n is equal to 1.
Then P1 from 1 to 2
is equal to 3/4.
So the probability from 1 to 2
in two steps is equal to 3/8.
So it goes 1/4 plus
3/4, 3/4 plus 1/4.
It should be equal
to 3/8, right?
Is that right?
OK.
And then it when P1,2 to 3, if
there are three transitions
from 1 to 2, then it's
equal to 9/16.
So if for 2, if I want
to transition
from 2 to 2 n steps--
so P2,2 is equal to 1/4.
So it just stayed by itself.
So P2,2 in two steps, you
don't have a choice.
You have to go from
3/4 to 3/4.
So that's 9/16.
But For thing is I can also stay
here by 1/4 times 1/4.
So that gives me 5/8
and so forth.
So basically, the sequence going
from 1 to 2 is going to
be oscillating between 3/4,
3/8, 9/16, and so forth.
And then going from 2,2, it's
going to be oscillating too.
We can see that's
1/4, 5/8, 7/16.
So what happens is this
oscillation is going to
converge-- it's going to
approach, actually, 1/2.
So if we take the maximum of
these two, so P1,2 and P2,2--
because that means that we're
going to end at state 2.
And maximum over n steps, then
we just look at these two
numbers, the 3/4 and 1/4, if we
want the maximum, then it's
going to be 3/4.
For the 3/8 and 5/8, the maximum
is going to be 5/8,
the 9/16 and 7/16, the 9/16
will be the maximum.
And similarly, we compare it,
and we take the minimum.
And the minimum is 1/4,
3/8, and 7/16.
So we see that the maximum
is going to be--
it starts high.
And then it's going to
decrease toward 1/2.
And the minimum, what happens
is it's going to start low,
and then it's going to
increase to 1/2.
So this is exactly
this one here.
So P's transition makes this
an arbitrary finite-state
Markov chain.
Therefore, each j, this maximum
path, the most problem
path from i to j in n steps
is non-increasing n.
And the minimum is
non-decreasing n.
So you take n plus 1
steps from i to j.
So we're going to use that
Chapman-Kolmogorov equation.
So we take the first step
to some state k.
And then we go from
k to j in n steps.
But then we sum this
over all k.
But this P n for state to j to
k in n steps, I can just take
the maximum path.
So I take the most probable
path, the state that gives me
the most probable path, and
I substitute this in.
When I substitute this in,
obviously every one of these
guys is going to be less
than or equal to this.
Therefore, this outside
term is going to be
less than or equal.
So now this is just going
to be a constant.
So I sum over all k, and
then this term remains.
So therefore, what we know is
if I want to end up in state
j, and for n steps, if I
increase the step more, to n
plus 1, we know that this
probability is going to stay
the same or decrease.
It's not going to increase.
So you could do exactly the same
thing for the minimum.
So if this is going to be true,
then of course, if I
think the maximum of this,
it's also going to
be less than that.
Because this limit's true
for Markov chain.
It doesn't matter.
It just has to be a finite-state
Markov chain.
So this is true for any
finite-state Markov chain.
So if I take the maximum of
this, it's less than or equal
to the maximum of
the n-th step.
So n plus 1 steps, the path is
going to be less probable when
I take the maximum path, the
fact that I end up at
state j than n.
So before we complete the proof
of this theorem, let's
look at this case where P
is greater than zero.
So if we say Pis greater than
zero, this means that every
entry in this matrix is greater
than 0 for all i, j,
which means that this graph
is fully connected.
So that means you could get from
i to j in one step with
nonzero probability.
So if P is greater than 0--
and let this be the
transition matrix.
So we'll prove this first, and
then we'll extend it to the
arbitrary finite Markov chain.
So let alpha here is equal
to the minimum.
So it's going to be the minimum
element in this
transition matrix.
That means it's going to be the
state that contains the
minimum transition.
So let's call alpha-- it's
the minimum probability.
Excuse me.
So let all these
states i and j.
And for n greater than or equal
to 1, we have these
three expressions.
So this first expression says
this, that if I have an n plus
1 walk from i to j, I take
the most probable of
this walk over i.
So my choices, I can choose
my initial starting state.
In n plus 1 steps, I want
to end in state j.
So I pick the most
probable path.
If I minus this, which is the
least probable path--
but you get to minimize this
over i, over the initial
starting a state.
So this is less than or
equal to the n step.
It's exactly this term
here, the n step
times 1 minus 2 alpha.
So alpha is the minimum
transition probability in this
probability transition matrix.
So this one, it's not so
obvious right now.
But we are going to prove
that in the next slide.
So once we have this, we can
iterative on n to get the
second term.
So for this term inside here,
the most probable path to
state j in n steps, minus the
least probable path to state j
in n steps, is equal to exactly
the same thing in n
minus 1 steps times
1 minus 2 alpha.
So we just keep on iterating
this over. n, and then we
should get this.
So to prove this to this, we
prove it by induction.
We just have to prove the
initial step, that the maximum
single transition from l to j,
minus the minimum single
transition from l to j,
is less than or equal
to 1 minus 2 alpha.
So this one is proved
by induction.
So as n goes to infinity, notice
that this term is going
to go to 0.
because alpha is going to
be less than a 1/2.
Because if it's not, then we can
choose 1 minus alpha to be
this minimum.
So if this is going to 0, this
tells us the difference
between the most probable path
minus the least probable path,
the fact that we end
up in state j.
So if we take the limit as n
goes to infinity of both of
these, they should equal.
Because the difference of this,
we notice that it's
going down exponentially in n.
So this shows us that this
limit indeed does
exist and is equal.
We want to prove this first
statement over here.
So in order to prove this first
statement, what we're
going to do is we're going to
take this i, j transition in n
plus 1 transitions.
And then we're going to express
it as a function of n
transitions.
So the idea is this.
We're going to use the
Chapman-Kolmogorov equations
to have an intermediary step.
So in order to do this i to j
in n plus 1 steps, the most
probable path, we're going to
go to this intermediate step
and then on to the final step.
In this intermediate step,
it's going to be
a function of n.
So we're going to take one step
and then n more steps.
So what we're going to do is,
the intuition is, we're going
to remove the least
probable path.
So we remove that from
the sum in this
Chapman-Kolmogorov equation.
And then we have the sum
of everything else
except for that path.
And then the sum of everything
else, we're going to bound it.
Once we bound it, then we
have this expression.
The probability of i to j in n
plus 1 steps is going be a
function of a max and
a min over n steps
with a bunch of terms.
So that's the intuition of
how we're going to do it.
So the probability of ij going
from state i to state j in
exactly n plus 1 steps
is equal to this.
So it's the probability of
going from i to k, this
intermediate step.
We're going to take one
step to a state k.
And then we're going from
k to j in n steps,
summing over all k.
So this is exactly equal to this
with Chapman-Kolmogorov.
So now what happens is
we're going to take--
Before we get to this next step,
let's define this l min
to be the state that minimizes
p of ij, n over i.
So l min is going to be the
state that's going to be such
that the choices I pick over i
that in n steps I arrive at j
that's going to be the
least probable.
So this is l min over here.
It's the l min that
satisfies this.
Then I'm going to remove this.
So this is one state. l min is
just one state that i is going
to go to in this first step.
So we're going to remove
it from the sum.
So then, this is just here.
So that path goes from i to l
min times l to j in n steps.
So remove that one
path from here.
Now we have the sum over the
rest of the cases because we
just removed that.
So we have ik, kj to
n, where k is not
equal to that element.
So we removed that path, the one
that goes to that state.
But p of kj, n, the path that
goes from k to j in n steps,
we can just bound this term
by the maximum over l
from l to j of n.
So then we're going to take the
most probable path in n
steps such that we end
up in state j in n.
So this term right here is
bounded by this term.
Becomes is bounded by this,
that's why we have this less
than or equal sign.
So we just do two things from
this step, the first step, to
the second step.
So we took out the path that's
going to minimize that right
at the j-th node in n steps.
And then we bounded the rest
of this sum by this.
So when we sum this all up, this
is just a constant here.
And ik here is just all the
states that i is going to
visit except for this
one state, l min.
Since it's just all of them
except for that, it's just 1
minus the probability that it
goes from state i to l min.
So this sum here is just
equal to this sum here.
So this arrives here.
And this term is still here.
So going from here, what
happens is we just to
rearrange the terms.
So nothing happens right here.
It's just rearranging.
Now we have this term here.
So we look at this term, P
from i going to l min--
Remember, we chose alpha to be
the minimum single transition
probability, single
transition in that
probability transition matrix.
So i to l has to be
greater than that.
But the minus of this has to be
less than, the negative has
to be less than.
So this we can substitute
here.
So now we have this.
So the maximum over i of this
n plus 1 step actually shows
you the probability.
Because this I can write
as an n plus 1 step
path from i to j.
So if this is less than this
entire term, of course I can
write the maximum path
from i to j.
It also has to be less of
this because this is
satisfied for all i, j.
So therefore, we arrive at
this expression here.
So now we're kind of in good
business because we have the n
plus one step at transition, the
maximum path from i to j
in n plus 1 steps as a function
of n, which is what
we wanted, and a function
of this alpha.
So we repeat that
last statement.
And the last one is here,
the last line.
So now we have the maximum.
So now we want to do is we
want to get the minimum.
So we do exactly the same thing,
with the same proof.
And with the minimum, what we're
going to do is we're
going to look at the ij
transition in n plus 1 steps.
And then what we're going to do
is we're going to pull out
the maximum this time.
So we pull out the most probable
path in n steps such
that it arrives in state j.
Then we play the same game.
Would bound everything--
above, this time-- by the
minimum of the n step
transition probabilities
to get to j.
So once we do that, we get this
expression, very similar
to this one up here.
So now we have the maximum path,
which is n plus 1 steps
to j, and the minimum of
n plus 1 steps to j.
So we could take the difference
between these two.
So if you subtract these
equations here, so this first
equation minus the second
equation, we have this on the
right-hand side here and then
these terms over here on the
left-hand side.
So these terms over here on the
left-hand exactly proves
the first line of the lemma.
So the first line of
the lemma was here.
So now, to prove the second of
the lemma, remember, we're
going to prove this
by induction.
in order to prove this by
induction, we need to be first
initial step.
So the initial step is this.
So if I take the minimum
transition probability from l
to j, it has to be greater
than here with the alpha.
Because we said that alpha was
the absolute minimum of all
the single-step transition
probabilities.
Then the maximum transition
probability has to be greater
than or equal to
1 minus alpha.
It's just by definition
of what we choose.
So therefore, if I take this
term, the maximize minus the
minimum is just 1
minus 2 alpha.
So that's your first step in
the induction process.
So we iterate on n.
When we iterate on n,
one arrives at this
equation down here.
So this shows us from here that
if we take the limit as n
goes to infinity of this
term, this goes down
exponentially in n.
And both of these limits are
going to converge, and they
exist, and they're going
to be greater than 0.
So they'll be greater than 0
because of our initial state
that we chose this path with
a positive probability.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It seems to me that
alpha is the minimum, the
smallest number in the
transition matrix, right?
SHAN-YUAN HO: Alpha is the
smallest number, correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How does it fall from
that, like that?
So my is, the convergence
rate is related to f?
SHAN-YUAN HO: Yes,
it is, yeah.
In general, it doesn't really
matter because it's still
going to go down exponentially
in n.
But it does depend on
that alpha, yes.
Any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is the strength that
bound it proportional to the
size of that matrix, right?
SHAN-YUAN HO: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The strength
of that bound is
proportional to the size?
I mean, for a very large
finite-state Markov chain, the
strength of the bound is going
to be somewhat weak because
alpha is going to be--
SHAN-YUAN HO: Alpha has
to be less than 1/2.
AUDIENCE: OK, yes.
But the strength of the bound,
though, it's not a very tight
bound on max minus min.
Because in a large--
SHAN-YUAN HO: Yes.
This is just a bound.
And the bound is what
when we took it that
minimum-probability path,
the l min, remember?
The bound was actually
in here.
So we took the
minimum-probability path in n
steps, this l min that minimizes
this over i.
And then this is where this less
than or equal to here is
just a substitution.
Any other questions?
So what we know is that what
happens is that these
limited-state probabilities
exist.
So we have a finite
ergodic chain.
So if the probability of the
elements in this transition
matrix are all greater
than 0, we know
that this limit exists.
But we know that in general,
that may not be the case.
We're going to have some 0's
in our transition matrix.
So let's go back to the
arbitrary finite-state ergodic
chain with probability
transition matrix P. So in the
last slide, we showed that this
transition matrix P of h
is positive for h is equal to
M minus 1 squared plus 1.
So what we do is, we can apply
lemma 2 to P of h with this
alpha equals to minimum
going from i to j
in exactly h steps.
So why is this M minus
1 squared plus 1?
So in the last lecture--
so what it means is this.
So what is says is here.
This was an example given
in the last lecture.
It was a 6-state Markov chain.
So what it says is that if n is
greater than or equal to M
minus 1 squared plus 1-- in this
case, it's going to be 6.
So if n is greater than or equal
to 26, then I take P to
the 26th power, it means
it's greater than zero.
That meas if I take P to the
26th power, every single
element in this transition
matrix is going to be
non-zero, which means that you
can go from any state to any
state with nonzero probability,
as long as n is
bigger than that.
So basically, in this Markov
chain, if you go long enough,
long enough.
Then I say, OK, I want to go
from state i to state j in
exactly how many steps, there is
a positive probability that
this is going to happen.
So how did this bound
come across?
Well, for instance, in this
chain, if we look at P1,1 so
we have here?
So I'm going to look
at the transition
starting at state 1.
And I want to come back to 1.
So you definitely could come
back at 6, because these are
all positive probability 1.
So 6 is possible.
So n is equal to
6 is possible.
So what's the next one
that's possible? n is
equal to 11, right?
Then the next one is what?
16 is possible, right?
So 0 to 5 is impossible, is 0.
So if I pick n between 0 and 5,
and 7 and 10, you're toast.
You can't get back to 1.
And so forth.
So 18 is possible.
21--
let's see, is 17 possible?
Yeah, 17 is also possible.
AUDIENCE: Why is 16 possible?
SHAN-YUAN HO: So I go around
here twice, and
then the last one.
Is that right?
So if I go from here to here
to here to here, if I go
twice, and then one more
in the final loop.
AUDIENCE: That's 12.
SHAN-YUAN HO: Oh, it's 12?
No.
I'm going to go this inner
loop right here.
So if I go from 1 to 2 to 3
to 4 to 5 to 6, down to 2.
Then I go 3, 4, 5, 6, 1.
That's 11, isn't it?
So 16 is I'm going to go around
the inner loop twice.
OK.
Go ahead.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So everything 20 and
under is possible, right?
SHAN-YUAN HO: No.
Is 25 possible?
Tell me how you're going
to go 25 on this.
You just do the 5
loop 5 times.
SHAN-YUAN HO: Yeah, but I
want to go from 1 to 1.
You're starting in state 1.
AUDIENCE: Oh, oh, sorry.
OK.
SHAN-YUAN HO: 1 to 1, right?
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
OK, I see.
SHAN-YUAN HO: So you know for
this one that this bound is
actually tight.
So 25 is impossible.
So P1,1 of 25 is equal to 0.
There's no way you
can do that.
But for 26 on, then you can.
So what you're noticing is that
you need this loop of 6
here and that any combination
of 5 or 6 is possible.
So basically, in this particular
example, if n is
equal to 6k plus 5j, where k
is greater than or equal to
1-- because I need that final
loop to get back--
or j is greater than
or equal to 0--
So any combination of this one,
then I can express n.
I can go around it to give me
a positive probability of
going from state 1 to state 1.
So I'm going to prove this
using extremal property.
So we're going to take the
absolute worst case.
So the absolute worst case is
that for M state finite Markov
chain is if have a loop
of m and you have a
loop of m minus 1.
You can't just have
a loop of m.
The problem is now this
becomes periodic.
So we have to get rid
of the periodicity.
If you add a single group here,
that doesn't help you.
Then after 6, then it I get
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
That didn't have this.
So the absolute worst case for
an M state chain is going to
be something that
looks like this.
1 that goes to 2-- you're
forced to go to 2--
so forth, until state M. And
then this M is going to go
back to 2 or is going
to go back to 1.
So in other words, the worst
case is if you have--
n has to be some combination
of Mk plus M minus 1 j.
So this will be the worst
possible case for M state
Markov chain.
So it'll be Mk plus
M minus 1 j.
So k has to be greater
than or equal to 1.
And then j has to be greater
than or equal to 0, because
you need to come back.
So I'm just looking at the case
probability that I start
in state 1 and I come
back in state 1.
So all right.
So how do we get this bound?
Well, there is an identity
that says this.
If a and b are relatively prime,
then the largest n such
that it cannot be written-- so
we want to find the largest n
such that ak plus bj--
but this is k and j greater
than or equal to 0--
that it cannot be written
in this form.
The largest integer that it
cannot be written is ab
minus a minus b.
This takes a little bit to
prove, but it's not too hard.
If you want to know this proof,
come see me offline
after class.
This is the largest integer.
If n is equal to this,
it cannot be
written in this form.
But if n is greater than
this, then it can.
So all we do is substitute M
for a and M minus 1 for b
because M and M minus 1
are relatively prime.
But remember, we have a k here
that has to be greater than or
equal to 1.
We need at least one k.
But this so identity is for
k and j greater than 0.
So therefore, we have to
subtract out that k.
So therefore, we have M times
M minus 1, minus M
minus M minus 1.
But the thing is we have to add
the extra M, because this
k is greater than
or equal to 1.
So we have to add up one of
the M's because of this.
So this is just equal to
M minus 1, squared.
So this number, if n is equal
to this, it's the largest
number that it cannot be
written like that.
So therefore, we
have to add 1.
So that's why the bound
is equal to 1.
So the upper bound that n can
be written is going to be M
minus 1, squared plus 1.
AUDIENCE: Why did you add
the 1 at the end?
SHAN-YUAN HO: This one?
AUDIENCE: No, we've got to
do the 1 at the end.
AUDIENCE: We already
have that in there.
SHAN-YUAN HO: Oh, where is it?
No, it's in here, right?
AUDIENCE: No, it's not here.
SHAN-YUAN HO: Did I--
What are you talking about?
Where's the 1?
AUDIENCE: At the end,
the last equation.
SHAN-YUAN HO: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SHAN-YUAN HO: OK.
This is the "cannot," largest
n which you cannot write.
You cannot write this.
So this bound is tight.
It means that this is the
one that you can.
So if n is greater
than or equal to
this, then it's possible.
This is the largest
one it cannot.
Based on this, it cannot.
So we have to add the 1.
So therefore, in here,
you could do 26.
So starting from 26, 27,
28, you can do that.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Relatively prime,
what do you mean by
"relatively"?
SHAN-YUAN HO: There is a
greatest common divisor of 1.
So if we take h here, h is
going to be positive.
So if h is equal to M minus 1,
squared plus 1, then now all
the elements are positive.
Because we just proved that
we can write this--
every state can be visited by
any other state, with positive
probability.
So we say, looking at P, we know
that P of h is positive
for h greater than or
equal to this bound.
So what we do is we applied this
lemma 2 probability to
this transition matrix P of h,
where we have picked alpha--
remember, alpha is the
single-step transition
probability.
So instead of the single
transition, we have lumped
this P into P to the h power.
So it's h steps.
Because we proved the result
before for positive P. So this
P to the h is positive, so we
take alpha as the minimum from
i to j of P to the
h in this matrix.
So it doesn't really matter what
the value of alpha is,
only that it's going
to be positive.
And it has to be positive
because it's a probability.
So what happens is, if we follow
the proof of what we
just showed in the lemma, then
we show that the maximum path
from l to j--
h times M. So M is going
to be an integer, so in
multiples of h--
this upper limit is going to be
equal to the lower limit.
So the most probable path
is equal to the
least probable path.
So this is multiple of h's.
So if we take this as M goes
to infinity, this has
got to equal to--
Oops, this should be going
to pi sub j, excuse me.
This little temple here.
And this is going to
be greater than 0.
So the problem is now we've
shown it for multiples of h's,
what about the h's in between?
But the fact is that lemma 1,
we showed that this maximum
path from l to j in n is
not increasing in n.
So all those states, all those
paths, the transition
probability for the paths in
between these multiples of
h's, in between them it's
going to be not
increasing in n.
So even if we're taking these
multiples of each of h and n
here, here, here, and we know
that this limit is increasing,
we know that all the ones in
between them are also going to
be increasing to the same limit
because of lemma 1.
To remember, the maximum is
going to be not increasing,
and the minimum is going to be
non-decreasing in any one path.
So this must have the
same limit as
this multiple of this.
So the same limit applies.
So any questions on this?
So this is how we prove it for
the arbitrary finite-state
ergodic chain when we have some
0 probability transition
elements in the matrix P. So
the proof is the same.
So now for ergodic unichain.
So we see that this limit as n
approaches infinity from i to
j of n is going to just end up
in the steady-state transition
pi of j for all i.
So it doesn't matter what
your initial state is.
As n goes to infinity of this
path, as this Markov chain
goes on and on, you will end up
in state j with probability
pi sub j, where pi is this
probability vector.
So now we have this steady-state
vector, and then
we can solve for the
steady-state vector solution.
So this pi P is equal to pi.
Yeah?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Where did you prove
that the sum of all the pi j's
equal to one?
Because you say that we
proved that this is
the probability vector.
But did prove only that
it is non-negative?
SHAN-YUAN HO: It's
non-negative.
But the thing is because as n
goes to infinity, you have to
land up someone, right?
This is a finite-state
Markov chain.
You have to be somewhere.
And the fact that you have to be
somewhere, your whole state
space has to add up to 1.
Because it's a constant,
remember?
For every j, as n goes to
infinity, it goes to pi sub j.
So you have that for
every single state.
And then you have to
end up somewhere.
So if you have to end up
somewhere, the space has to
add up to one.
Yeah, good question.
So why are we interested
in this pi sub j?
The question is that because
in this recurrent class, it
tells us that as this goes to
infinity, we see this sequence
of states going back and
forth, back and forth.
And we know that as n goes
to infinity, we have some
probability, pi sub j, of
landing in state j, pi sub i
of landing in state
i, and so forth.
So it says that in the n step,
as n goes to infinity, that
this is the fraction of time
that, actually, that state is
going to be visited.
Because at each step, you have
to make a transition.
So it's kind of the expected
number of times per unit time.
So it's divide by n.
It's going to be that fraction
of time that you're going to
visit that state.
It's the fraction of time
that you're going
to be in that state.
It's this limiting state as
n gets very, very large.
So we will see that in the next
few chapters when we do
renewal theory that this will
come into useful play.
And we give a slightly different
viewpoint of it.
So it's very easy to extend this
result to a more general
class of ergodic unichains.
So remember the ergodic
unichains, now we have
increased these transient
states.
So before, we proved this.
We just proved it for it
contains exactly one class.
It's aperiodic, so we have no
cycles, no periodicity in this
Markov chain.
And so we know that the
steady-state transition
probabilities have a limit.
And the upper limit and the
lower limit of these paths as
they go to infinity--
in fact, they end up in
a particular state--
has a limit.
And we have this steady-state
probability vector that
describes this.
So now we have these
transient states.
So these transient states of
this Markov chain, what
happens is there exists a path
that this transient state is
going to go to a recurrent
state.
So once it leaves this transient
state, it goes to
recurrent state.
It's never going to come back.
So there is some probability,
alpha, of leaving the
class at each step.
So there's some transition
probability in this transient
state that's going
to be alpha.
And the probability of remaining
in this transient
state is just 1 minus
alpha to the n.
And this goes down
exponentially.
So what this says is that
eventually, as n gets very
large, it's very, very hard to
stay in that transient state.
So it's going to go out of
the transient state.
And then it will go into
the recurrent class.
So when one does the analysis
for this, what happens in the
probability in this steady-state
vector is those
transient states, this pi,
will be equal to 0.
So this distribution is only
going to be non-zero for
recurrent states in this
Markov chains.
And the transient states will
have probability equal to 0.
In the notes, they just
extend the argument.
But you need a little bit
more care to show this.
And it divides the transient
states into a block and then
the recurrent classes into
another block and then shows
that these transient states'
limiting probability is going
to go to 0.
So let's see.
So this says just what I said,
that these transient states
decay exponentially, and one
of the paths will be taken,
eventually, out of it.
So for ergodic unichains, the
ergodic class is eventually
entered, and then steady state
in that class is reached.
So every state j, we
have exactly this.
The maximum path from
i to j in n steps--
and the minimum path.
We look at the minimum path in
n steps and the maximum path
in n steps.
And for each n, we take the
limit as n goes to infinity.
These guys, these limits are
exactly equal, and it equals
to this pi sub j, which is
equal to the j state.
So your initial states, how you
went the paths that you
have gone is completely
wiped out.
And all that matters is
this final state,
as n gets very large.
So the difference here is that
pi sub j equals 0 for each
transient state, and it's
greater than 0 for the
recurrent state.
So other finite Markov chains.
So we can consider a
Markov chain with
several ergodic classes.
Because we just considered it
with one ergodic class.
So if the classes don't
communicate, then you just
consider it separately.
So you figure out the
steady-state transition
probabilities for each of
the classes separately.
But if you have to insist on
analyzing the entire chain P,
then this P will have m
independent steady-state
vectors and one non-zero
in each class.
So this P sub n is still going
to converge, but the rows are
not going to be the same.
So basically, you're going
to have blocks.
So if you have one class, say 1
through k is going to be in
one class, and then k through
l is going to be another
class, and then l through z is
going to another class, you
have a block.
So this steady-state vector
is going to be in blocks.
So you can see the recurring
classes only communicate
within themselves.
Because these don't
communicate, so they're separate.
So you could have a lot of 0's
in limiting state, if you look
at this, P sub n goes
to infinity.
So there m set of rows,
one for each class.
And a row for each class k
will be non-zero for the
elements of that class.
So then finally, if we
have periodicity.
So now if we have a periodic
recurrent chain with period d.
We had the two where it's
just a period of 2.
So with periodicity, what you
do is you're going to divide
these classes into d
different states.
So you have to go
to one state--
So if there's d states, this is
a period of d, you separate
or you partition the states into
d of them, d subclasses,
with a cycle rotation
between them.
So basically, each time unit,
you have to go from one class
to the next class.
And then we do that, then for
each class, you could have the
limiting-state probability.
So in other words, you are
looking at this transition
matrix, pi d.
Because when it cycles, it
totally depends on which one
you start out at.
But if you look at the d
intervals, then that becomes
the ergodic class by itself.
And there are exactly
d of them.
So the limit as n approaches
infinity of P of nd, this
thing also exists, but exists in
the subclass sense of there
is d subclasses if it
has a period of d.
So that means a steady state
is reached within each
subclass, but the chain
rotates from
one subclass to another.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: In this case, if we
do a simple check with 1 and
2, with 1 and 1, it
doesn't converge.
SHAN-YUAN HO: No, it does.
It is 1, converges to 1.
So it's 1, and then it's
going to be 1.
AUDIENCE: It's 1, 1,
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
So you go here?
Like, it's reached--?
SHAN-YUAN HO: No, no.
It converges for here.
But this d is equal to
2, in that case.
So you have to do nd,
so you've got
to look at P squared.
So if I look at P squared,
I'm always a 1--
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
That's converging.
The other one is 2,
2, 2, 2, 2, 2.
That's also converging.
OK.
So is there any other questions
about this?
OK, that's it.
Thank you.